number one um we're going to have jerry
lee talking about lower balance or
robust estimation
thank you
all right cool thanks
uh so yeah so this talk is about like
i don't know pretty interesting
direction
i'm not gonna lie some of the results
are sort of like i put it towards there
for like a reason like sort of like
you know not super satisfying but i
think the direction is really nice and i
think the connection we draw at least to
me feels supernatural so
hopefully there's something more that
smarter people
can figure out
okay so this talk is about the following
basic problem in statistics since robust
mean estimation
is the following problem so let d be a
distribution over r little d
and then in second example from d we get
like the corrupted set of samples from d
and what does that mean
we say that a sample is epsilon
corrupted from d it feels
generated via the following process
first you sample and samples id from
this distribution d but then you give
them to an adversary
and then they get to inspect and change
the natural fraction of these samples
however they want and then the resulting
samples are sort of returned to you in
like some arbitrary order
okay
the remastered estimation problem is a
very well-studied problem um like dating
back to sort of statistics in like the
60s or whatever and just give an epsilon
cup instead of samples um from this
distribution d recover the mean of this
distribution as well as you can
okay so this is the basic question that
we're going to be considering in this
talk
uh any questions so far
so
it should be clear that like without
additional assumptions that this problem
is like completely impossible like i
need some regularity assumptions on my
distribution d
so what are uh what what are the sorts
of like assumptions that you make one
class of like
standard assumptions you make is a
bounded moment control my distribution
okay
uh and the reason why this is like nice
for this problem is because of the
following
fact which is like kind of relatively
easy to prove
if i have a univariate distribution um
with mean mu and bounded central case
moments
so you know so let's say all the moments
of the degree k are bounded by at most
one
um
then if i have like a sufficiently large
set of corrupted samples from my
distribution there's some relatively
easy to compute estimator you just take
the
like truncated amine
which achieves error which is uh o of
epsilon to the one minus one over k
okay and this is type
so this is like information
theoretically type
in one dimension okay so this is sort of
the rate that you might expect one uh
epsilon to the one minus one over k
in particular if you have if i found a
covariance this corresponds to k being
two so then my error here is like
epsilon to the one half
okay
and it turns out that this is not only
true in sort of
uh one dimension but also true in higher
dimensions as well so this exact same
statement with just some things changed
so if
just where can i find this fact is this
does this go back to this
i guess is what you would call it
like i think you can you can just uh
like
like sort of the the
but you just do something you truncate
the epson tail like the largest and
smallest and usually do the computation
and it's like a couple lines it's like
in some lecture notes somewhere i'm sure
or by his book
yeah
hopefully yeah anyways okay so if i have
a dimensional distribution
and i have bound to central case moments
in every direction
which is
so if i take any univariate projection
of my distribution and i compute the
central case moment in that direction uh
this is bounded by one
then given an epsilon corrupted set of
samples i can achieve l2 error to my
mean to the true mean with some
inefficient estimator
that also achieves error epsilon to 1
minus 4k and crucially this is the
difference between the univariate and
the uh you know
high-dimensional settings the univariate
estimator is just like this truncated
mean it's very easy to compute this
estimator is not necessarily or that
it's not a priori sort of efficient
but from an information theoretical
standpoint this is still the truth
so this is one sort of common assumption
the other there's another sort of more
recently introduced assumption which is
like directly sort of
motivated by this problem of robust
mutation and is this uh assumption of
called resilience which is first
introduced by this paper in uh in 2017
by steinhardt chariqar valiant
and they say a distribution d is sigma
epsilon resilient if for any probability
event e
that has
occurs with probability at least one
minus epsilon under my distribution d
then the conditional mean condition on
this you know fairly likely event is
pretty close to true
uh mean of the distribution
it's the most sigma and l2
okay and like you can sort of guess i
mean this is like directly catered
towards sort of robust mean animation
with these parameters uh they're sort of
it's not so hard to see a connection
between these two between like you know
this assumption and robust mean
estimation
uh and in some sense this is a weaker
assumption than down to moments because
just by like you know
markov's inequality
bounded moments imply resilience sort of
at every scale so notice resilience here
only applies for like you know two
parameters sigma and epsilon like it's
fixed for these two parameters
um but boundary moments say that you
know if i bound to k-th moments then for
all epsilon sufficiently small at least
it is epsilon to the one minus one over
k comma epsilon resident
okay
so sort of
resilience is like at a very fixed scale
like i have sort of this control
boundary moment implies sort of this
resilience
for all epsilon like even in like the
far tails
okay
but the main fact that was also proven
in the same paper which is that if i
have you know uh epsilon crypto set of
samples from a sigma epsilon resilient
distribution
then i can achieve error which is a
order sigma
and again if you plug in sort of this
result
for the sigma you get you recover also
the same results for
bounded moments
so
these two assumptions make sense
oh yeah and this this again is
computationally inefficient so it gets
some sort of brute force search over
like all subsets and stuff like this
so right so so far i've only talked
about inefficient algorithms just like
you know
uh completely information theoretic but
what if i care about runtime now
then for this specific setting
the actual results are quite limited in
particular sort of we only have results
for the founded second moment setting
and what do i mean by this so there's
this result by
dick nicholas kane kamath myself moitra
stewart
in 2017 that says that if you have two
bounded moments so if you have bounded
covariance
then there is indeed an efficient
algorithm which achieves air root
epsilon which is that's not to one minus
one over k when k is equal to so this
sort of matches the information
you know bounds when k is equal to
similarly if you have an assumption on
resilience which is sort of corresponds
to the bounded second moment assumption
so this is sort of like epsilon of one
half versus epsilon
you can almost match sort of the
information theory degrees in that
setting up to this root log factor
okay
uh
and then like
it's like if all we want to make are
these sorts of assumptions like bounded
moments and nothing else then these are
like the only results we have
you only want to assume like upper
bounds at the moment this is sort of it
it's not surprising because there's a
lot of work in this area of course
there's a lot of results in sort of
restricted cases
um with additional assumptions
so in particular if you have found okay
moments and the fact that you have
boundary case moments in every direction
has some sort of sos proof
then you can show this is like based on
some joint work with sam and also
by uh
kathari steinhardt
um that you can achieve sort of this
error that's not to the one minus one
over k
in at least poly time when k is constant
okay
i believe you can actually improve this
case square to okay now but
additionally you can also prove in sort
of earlier works if if you have
subgration moments so if you have like
lots of bound moments and you have known
variance so say you know the variance's
identity then you can achieve error
which is like epsilon to root log
sorry almost
like
nearly epsilon here in poly time
and this wasn't written down anywhere as
far as i can tell but like sort of the
same result
i think was written down in your book
for the first time is that if you have
bounty case moments and also the same
assumption of known variance so if you
like know the variance exactly not just
like upper bounds on it you can also
achieve this epsilon to the one minus
one over k
all the time but sort of all these
things have some caveats like you need
to some additional algebraic structure
on your distribution to achieve these
results so if all you want to assume and
this is sort of weird right because like
statistically all i really need is sort
of concentration properties
but you know these two things at least
say i need some sort of
anti-concentration in some sense and
this also requires some like additional
algebraic structure which is not like
statistically necessary
so somehow there's like something weird
going on here that like i really need
something it seems
additional to like do something beyond
root epsilon to this end
okay so let me tell you morally why we
might suspect there are like really
genuine barriers to this problem
the algorithms for sort of second
elements rely on
something that all people alexander
madrid coined this term spectral
signatures which is sort of stuck at
least for me
um which is basically the following fact
if mu hat is the empirical mean of the
corrupted data set
and if you know this distribution has
bounded second moments in all directions
and suppose the empirical mean is far
from the true mean in my distribution mu
in particular it is like little omega
root ups on the way
then if i let v be the top eigenvector
of the empirical covariance i can think
of as the optimizer of this quadratic
form over my samples
there should be max here like that
then you have this following property
which is that if i sort of take the the
quadratic form in this direction and i
project all the points
sort of
the sum of this the contribution of the
quadratic form from the bad points is
like much bigger this 2 is like
arbitrary this could be like a hundred
or a thousand depending on if you care
about constants
the sum of the uh contributions to the
quadratic form from the bad points is
like much bigger than the sum of the
contribution from the good
which you should think of as this is
very suspicious because like this is a
small set this is a big set
so somehow like even though this is a
very small set they're contributing a
lot to the variance in this direction
and this is sort of
allows you to make algebraic oh sorry
algorithmic progress because you know
all these things are efficiently
computable in particular i compute the
top eigenvector
very efficiently
and it turns out you can do the same
thing when k is higher the problem is
that instead of having quadratic
optimization problem like this sort of
uh you know degree two thing i just need
to take case moments and here this is
like where you get into like the land of
like computational attractability
so in particular you have the following
correspondence suppose i bounded case
moments in every direction
and now let's make a weaker assumption
on like how far are these things let's
assume it's like little o omega of
epsilon to the one minus one over k
which is like sort of the error we're
going for
then what i can do is i can take v to be
the maximizer of like the two decay norm
so i just take v to be the like the
maximizer of this degree k polynomial
over my samples
now if i do so i get more or less the
same
thing when i raise things to the case
powers
okay so in other words the optimizer of
this two decay norm
of my empirical covariance gives you an
op direction where the outliers are
large on average
and so all that remains is sort of
compute these things
but this is a tensor optimization
problem and these things are hard and
this is sort of like
the fundamental sort of idea of like why
there might be like real issues with
doing this
does that make sense
and so this is like why one might
suspect there are sort of real barriers
to this problem assuming sort of that
you think that this is the only thing
you can do which is in some sense
our methods are like ways to try to
convince you that maybe this is like the
only thing you can do
this is sort of an interesting uh point
as well because
you know one might ask given in
particular the context of the previous
stocks can you do this can you prove
like sort of escu hardness
problems
and
the answer is surprisingly no
like
not only is it like we don't know a
proof but in fact there is an sq
algorithm and this is sort of like a
fact that typically doesn't come up very
much in sort of
you know sq usually we think of sq as
like a subclass of efficient algorithm
this is not technically true because in
particular i'm allowed to do inefficient
queries
after i've done my you know sq
algorithms
in particular the hardness for this
problem is just like literally computing
the maximizer of this two decay norm
of something i know right literally of
the empirical covariance matrix
so i can like literally estimate the
k-th moment tensor the high accuracy
anytime detail or decay and then all i
need to do is like you know i've i've
written down towards what the monomials
are i know what the coefficients of my
polynomial optimization problem should
be i can just like literally solve this
problem like because sq doesn't care
about sort of that runtime
so in fact for this problem there is
like an efficient escrow algorithm
so in other words like if we're going to
look for like hardness we sort of have
to rely on other techniques
which is kind of interesting and also it
motivates
sort of why we're looking at these other
hypotheses other like sort of
reasons for hardness
so let me talk about what we actually
did
so the first sort of two results are
saying that
if we're going to go like on using
current techniques like which are
relying on sort of you know
uh
finding these like large eigenvectors or
not eigenvectors but maximizes like two
decay norms and
resilience things
this is probably hard so the first
theorem is like barely even our theorem
um
it's really already more or less
occurred uh in this like paper by oh god
brock brandel harrow counter
sawyer zao and we sort of like did it
um
we more or less sort of give like a
refinement of this theorem
that says that it's hard to just compute
this like maximization from
4k greater than i guess i should say k
greater than like four or so
actually you can prove this for k
anything strictly greater than two
and
yeah
oh i mean so you sort of want
sort of like the exact uh constant of
hardness sort of
this is
the reason why you sort of want this c
to the k over two in general is because
like um
yes he's bigger than one yeah yeah but
you know i stated things for like
moments and surrounded by literally one
but
so the most natural thing is not just
like case moments are literally one k
it's like the most natural things like
the case moment just like looks like the
case moments of a gaussian which goes
like k to the k over two and so you want
to say like a multiplicative
approximation to that is hard and sort
of that's like why this is sort of
or in other words just saying like uh a
constant factor approximation to like
the k two became the norm like not just
like the k moment but like the k moment
to the one over k
again now this is nice and sometimes
it's already more or less we also show
that under the small set expansion
hypothesis
uh the problem of like certifying a
resilient subset is also hard so
given vectors and determine if the
uniform distribution is
over these vectors is like
pretty resilient or like far from
brazilian
and obviously all these parameters are
like not like tight
there is asterisk here which i'll
explain in a second hopefully
okay
yeah you can take this to be i mean so
the small side expansion hypothesis like
the qualitative version of it that you
can use sort of you can sort of vary
this constant
to like be anything i'm sure
you can take this and you can just like
you know depending on what you're
assuming is hard for ssd
[Music]
yeah
yeah particularly because like i'm
showing even like a constant improvement
it's hard this presumably shows that
doing anything below you know little
omega root epsilon is like also
difficult
okay but these are sort of not directly
about robust mutant destination these
are sort of like if i want to solve
robust mean estimation i need new
techniques i can't just like do these
things
um what would be more interesting is
like a direct reduction to sort of
directly showing that robust mutation is
hard
and this is what we sort of do
um so what we show is that under a
slight variance of the smallest
expansion i bought this
uh the following problem is hard for
some parameters alpha beta
given vectors b1 through bn in our d
such that there exists a set
so i said the uniform distribution over
this restricted like slightly smaller
set
is resilient
uh the goal of this problem is to output
a vector which is close beta beta root
apps on close to the empirical mean
restricted to the subset
okay so why why does this demonstrate
sort of hardness of like robust meaning
a robust mean animation and resilience i
can take my distribution to simply be
like my corrupted distribution
i can take the true distribution to be a
uniform distribution over
this behind the set
right and then i can take the corrupted
distribution to be the uniform
distribution over literally everything
and then you know if i draw enough
samples i'll recover the support exactly
so like i don't really have to worry
about
sort of like the support or anything or
like samples versus like given a
description sort of everything here is
like supported on polynomially many
points
and then you can just check
you know literally this is the robust
mutant estimation problem for that set
of distributions like you know i want to
recover the period the the true mean
which is the
the trimming of my distribution is
literally the average of these bis and
i'm given samples from something which
is
that's not close
so the source says that
uh you know robust mean estimation for
under this resilience you cannot beat
sort of
a root epsilon even by like constant
factors
if i sample there will be some repeats
and stuff right it won't be exactly the
same yeah but if i tell you sort of like
if i tell you like the distribution it
has like n support which i can you can
just literally just yeah
so it says that even improving upon root
epsilon by constants even if i have some
sort of assumption on like
you know the resilience here and some
improved assumption on the resilience
here is probably
hard probably not going to tell you
anything about the techniques or very
little about the techniques
given time but
let me tell you at least about something
i found kind of curious about the
sponsored expansion hypotheses
emphasis on the c's
okay so what is a small side expansion
um
if i have a regular graph g on n
vertices i can let fee sub g
of s for any subset denote the expansion
of s this is simply the probability that
a random walk starting in s
leaves s in one step
[Music]
okay
and then i can define this quantity
known as the expansion profile of
g which is simply the minimum expansion
of any subset of size delta n
okay so this is some function
now the original small set expansion
hypothesis which was like first
introduced in this paper by rock avenger
store
is the following assumption that says
that or a hypothesis that for any for
every constant delta there's some
epsilon i said it is empty hard to
determine
if fee sub g of epsilon is at least one
minus delta or a fee sub g of epsilon is
at most delta and for people who are
like
more familiar with sse i'm sorry i'm
switching to constants dealt and epsilon
but it's like more convenient for me
okay this is like the original like if
you look at the paper of ragaman
destroyer hypothesis of sse
there's another natural variant of
business c where instead of looking at a
piece of g of exactly delta i look at a
piece of d for all delta prime less than
delta
so for every constant delta there's an
epsilon greater than zero such as mp
hard to determine if p sub g of epsilon
prime is greater than my delta for all
epsilon prime less than epsilon
or if there exists some epsilon prime
such that the expansion is pretty bad
for that epsilon prime
so i'm going to call the first one for
obviously reasons sse equals and the
other one s is e less than equals
okay somewhat frustratingly
these are considered like
interchangeable literature but as far as
i know they're not
i'm not like an expert on this stuff but
we like asked prasad and like he was
like yeah
um so like that's some evidence i guess
in particular
so the original paper of ragam just
swear shows some reduction from sc
equals
to uh to unique games so if s z equals
is true then unique games is hard
reductions of this form are like not
necessarily known for like the other
version and equivalences between these
notions are not known like this is
actually as far as i know just not in
the literature and like
seems somewhat non-trivial
but they consider these two things to be
roughly interchangeable in particular
you know this previous paper by
i'm not going to try again but you know
by the the hyper contractivity sum of
squares paper
they refer to this lesser equals to as
the sum of a small set of connection
hypothesis
but
and you know most of the time this seems
like not a huge deal in particular it
seems like it's okay
but so in our setting it turns out
there's like a real distinction between
these two problems particularly the
lesser equal diversions talks about
expansion sort of at all scales less
than or equal delta or epsilon just like
how moments are like resilience at all
scales for us
and so there seems like there's actually
a natural
you know
sort of correspondence for us where like
if you assume the ssc equals you get
some same about resilience
and if you assume scc lesser equals you
get something about bounded moments
so when i said like you know i had these
asterisks and previously i meant that
for the resilience one i meant sse
equals and for another one i meant ssc
glasses equals
weird but you know we'll go with it
i am going to skip this but this is a
really nice sort of like the reason why
you might expect
i can just talk about this very briefly
okay so let me tell you sort of at a
high level about like
what the connection is between sort of
um
multi expansion and like resilience and
you know all these things about
robustness
this is a technique that we didn't
introduce this is just like a technique
that
was already considered but it seems like
a very natural connection to our setting
so given the graph g we let m sub g be
denote the stochastic n by n random walk
matrix associated to this graph
and then let let me let uh a sub a be
the matrix whose columns are the unit
vectors of mg with eigenvalue at least
one half
okay
and because g is a regular matrix or a
regular graph sorry
one of the eigenvalue values or one
eigenvectors is literally all one's
vector so without loss of generality
assume the first one is
all ones i uh vector
and then my the isotropic spectral
embedding or the spectral embedding is
simply i take the rows of this matrix
as my embedding so each row corresponds
to some
node right there's n
uh there's n rows so each one
corresponds to some row
and this gives you some embedding of g
okay so if i just take the rows of this
matrix
that is and
if i scale them by ruden it turns out
that makes things isotropic and we just
call the scale version the isotropic
spectral embedding
okay
so now what i'm going to do is i'm like
it turns out that my reduction is
literally i'm just going to take
resilience over the uniform distribution
over the isotropic spectral embedding
in particular sort of you have these two
key lemmas i was hoping to prove the
simple one because it's really like
five minutes but
i'm not going to
but these really do say sort of you know
expansion is closely tied to whether or
not a small set
has like a large deviation in norm
particularly the first limit says that
for every subset t
oh and note that you know sets um you
know events of probability epsilon
over the uniform distribution over these
uh vectors literally corresponds
to like you know sets subsets besides
epsilon n
so the first line that says that for
every set
um you have this following property
which is that the
uh the mean of the set the alternator of
this mean of this
of the mean is at least sort of some
quantity which is determined
by one-half minus expansion so in
particular
if i'm not expanding meaning that fee
sub g is small of my set
then this quantity is large
so if i have a non-expanding set this
corresponds to a subset whose mean has
large norm
okay
so this says you know non-expansion and
plots is non-resilient set because
there's some set which is very far away
on the other hand if
uh
i have all my sets are well expanding so
p sub g is always large
then every set
every uh the mean of every small subset
is bounded
so the upper bounded by this quantity
was slightly nasty
but don't worry about it but the point
is this is the lesser equal to
yeah
this is sort of the connection sort of
somehow
you know uh small non-expanding sets
directly correspond to like small
subsets which like shift the mean by a
lot
i was going to prove this this is like
really like a very short calculation but
you know what i'm going to skip it
but that's sort of the high level
idea sort of why you might expect
uh these things come up
so now i'm going to talk very briefly
about like how to try to get some
reduction directly from robust mean
estimation
we would like to try to use the same
embedding the problem is that robust
mean animation is like a promise problem
namely that we need to guarantee that
like there exist like even in the case
where there is a small non-expanding set
once you remove that set the rest of the
graph is well-behaved
or the rest of the distribution is like
resilient to whatever and this is just
like not true under ssc as far as we
know
so we're just going to assume it this is
a
you know this is like
yeah we're not complexity here we can do
whatever we want
so we're just going to say that uh
if you're like
uh
we're going to consider this mute this
more restricted class of
graphs where there exists exactly one
small non-expanding set
and we're going to consider this new
assumption which we call the unique
small again smallest expansion
hypothesis where this unique is
unrelated to the unique games but
essentially it is still empty hard to
like find this the unique
small non-expanding set
and under this hypothesis we prove
that robust meanings nation is hard and
as far as we know again the source of
this is literally we asked facade and
he's like yeah that seems plausible this
is also probably hard but we don't know
so that's pretty much it
lots of open directions here i think
this connection is really nice in
particular like we didn't do any work
like you know our reduction is like
super easy right literally take this
like standard thing this isotropic or
this special embedding and just like say
hey look if it's like there's a small
step if there's like a small set
expander
then you know
it's resilient otherwise it's not
there's like supernatural connection
um in general i feel like there's more
to be explored here so one sort of more
complexity theoretic reaction which
really bothers me
is like the fact that the community sort
of completed these two
non-equivalent hypotheses but maybe
that's not like my question to consider
you know
um you know another natural direction is
just like can we resolve can we like
prove robust media destination is hard
from this more standard assumption not
like unique small side expansion or
whatever we call it
and can you also prove
uh hardness for other robust estimation
tests but like more generally speaking
just trying to understand
this like seeming very seemingly natural
connection and like if there's actually
anything more do it because it does seem
like there should be
that's it thanks
[Applause]
all right maybe we can take one question
well survey
so sort of like the same thing like
trying to beat one over route alpha
under like better
an
china
i guess the reason why that was
something was because it um
there again there's like a variant of
the ssc assumption which this time
actually you can prove is exactly
equivalent testasy which almost has this
sort of like list decodable structure
so like there was like it was very we
felt like it was very close to actually
getting some reduction here
but we didn't we didn't know how to do
it
so you get a little like
maybe the answer is much worse if you
have any faults
in between between the roots
[Music]
and uh
all right
for our final touch we'll have serpy
from